[Musique]
mission accomplie du moins pour la
démonstration de force 5 à 8000
personnes salariées habitants sous
traitants gilet jaune belfort s'est levé
comme un seul homme pour défendre son
patrimoine industriel
même les élus ont réglé leurs pas sur
celui du peuple
présentant le front uni de rigueur
lorsque leur est grave mais d'autres
heure cruciale celle là aussi sont à
venir
mercredi pour la troisième fois la
direction tentera de tenir la réunion
censée lancer son plan social mais à
paris et non plus à belfort et ce pour
tenter de contourner l'obstacle lundi et
vendredi ses cadres avait dû renoncer
face à la détermination des salariés
et puis viendra le très attendu rendez
vous judiciaire jeudi le tribunal de
grande instance de belfort devra se
prononcer en référé sur une éventuelle
suspension du plan social ni plus ni
moins l'intersyndicale auteurs de la
plainte accuse la direction de n'avoir
pas étudié d'alternative des pistes de
diversification qui permettrait de
réduire le nombre de licenciements
un calendrier qui égrène les jours et
met les nerfs à rude épreuve
en l'absence de réponse de l'état et si
rien ne se passe cette semaine
l'intersyndicale à d'ores et déjà
prévenu elle ne répondra plus de rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]